the great nobel laureate stephen
weinberg once said that physics thrives
on crisis and in 1989 he said physics
was short on crises but luckily for us
today
physics is chock full of them we're
going to talk about possibly two cosmic
conundrums come along into the
impossible
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
i've talked with adam reese another
nobel laureate about the so-called
hubble tension and that seems to
indicate that the agreements between the
early universe measurements of the
hubble constants and the late universe
measurements of the hubble constant
differ difference that is irreconcilable
now astronomers have found a possible
resolution to the hubble tension that
relies on nothing more exotic than your
kitchen's refrigerator magnet
astronomers are used to measuring
magnetic fields they pervade the cosmos
there's even a magnetic field associated
with your body and birds use magnetic
fields to navigate the earth has a
magnetic field the solar system has a
magnetic field our galaxy has a magnetic
field the clusters of galaxies that we
observe have magnetic fields the
question is
is there a primordial or fundamental
cosmic primordial magnetic field
recently a radio galaxy survey by the
lofar collaboration discovered a
massive magnetic field pervading dozens
or maybe hundreds of galaxies and the
question is how could you get such a
ginormous magnetic field pervading not
just a single galaxy but hundreds or
dozens of hundreds thousands of galaxies
at the same time what are galaxy
clusters and why are they so important
to the study of magnetic field well
galaxy clusters are the most massive of
all cosmic objects that are so-called
gravitationally bound they're associated
in the same way that the earth is
associated with the sun by the force of
gravity and they're in motion in this
case they're associated by the forces
primarily of gravity due to the dark
matter that surrounds these galaxies and
in fact their properties led zwicky back
in the 1930s to conjecture the existence
of so-called dark matter validated by
vera rubin these galaxy clusters grow by
creating small structures onto bigger
ones in the process of gobbling up
smaller and smaller galaxies to make a
more massive and massive galaxy cluster
they emit low frequency radio wave
emission and that's due to the charged
particles mainly the electrons that move
in magnetic fields of these galaxies we
can detect the motion of those electrons
the emission in the radial frequency and
use that to as a proxy to measure the
magnetic field that cause these
electrons to move with the accelerations
that they're observed when the lofar
scientists as discussed in this paper
shown here described a measurement of
this massive galaxy cluster they were
overwhelmed by the size of the implied
magnetic field permeating these galaxy
clusters
so they sought out computer simulations
to predict how large a magnetic field a
cosmic cluster of galaxies should
exhibit one possibility would be that it
had been essentially created earlier on
in the cosmic history maybe back
primordially closer to the big bang than
ever thought possible before
now this question has bearing not only
on the aspects of the formation of
galaxies and clusters and their magnetic
fields but also on the problem of
whether or not the universe's expansion
rate is really different at early times
versus late times for if there were an
early magnetic field in the universe
that could help to resolve why the
measurements of the universe's expansion
rate the hubble constant at early times
via cosmic microwave background
measurements differ so violently with
those by late time observers such as
adam reese and wendy friedman and others
that measure the hubble constant using
galaxies as we observe them at low
redshift my colleague and friend levon
pagosian at simon fraser university
suggested that we might not need to
appeal to exotic physics the new type of
of energy or mass or matter but rather
just to invoke something that we know
and love from our kitchen refrigerator
namely magnetic fields what magnet what
about it
cosmologists have known that magnetic
fields play an important role in all
gravitationally bound systems but they
didn't know if there were any unbound
magnetic fields magnetic fields not
associated with clusters and magnetic
fields have fascinated scientists since
the year 1600 when the first scientific
study by william gilbert
looked at the properties of lodestones
these are naturally occurring magnetized
rocks that people have been using as
compasses he conjectured back in the
1600s in his famous book called the
magnet
that perhaps the magnetic force
originates from a type of force field
that he called
reminiscent of a soul
but he correctly did summarize that the
earth possesses a property that makes it
effectively a great magnet
and that lodestones will lock towards
the poles of the earth now the question
is can you get a non-dynamic in other
words not a rotational generation force
for the magnetic field in the universe
so magnetic fields are ubiquitous they
essentially are unblockable they can
only be blocked by things like
superconductors and laboratory-generated
cancellation fields that we do use
throughout our experiments so you can't
really shield it so they pervade
everything so they can reach out across
vast distances in the cosmos now an
interesting study done over a decade ago
published what's called a lower limit on
the amount of cosmic magnetism this is
fascinating by looking at the
non-observation
of what are called tev blazars and their
halos we don't see an effect how one
would expect to see around very distant
blazars which are highly energetic uh
nuclei of active galaxies that these
blazers would produce a halo due to
positron electron annihilation that
we've talked about in other videos
but that phenomenon would lead to a
burst of gamma radiation that we should
see surrounding these distant objects
the fact that we don't observe these
halos led to a lower limit on the amount
of cosmic magnetic field energy present
when these blazars are in their active
phase this magnetic field would cause
the divergence of positron electron
pairs because they're opposite charge we
could use that non-observation to say
there is a magnetic field close to these
blazars which themselves are at high
redshift therefore there is strong
evidence for a minimum amount of cosmic
magnetic field energy pervading our
universe now how did that get there that
is of course an open question
looking for the signals as observed by
lofar implies that these galaxy clusters
have enormous amounts of magnetic energy
and that they are also at great distance
and therefore great time and look back
sense from our observational vantage
point on earth so the lofar team doesn't
know for sure what caused the magnetic
field to permeate the filaments that
they saw i should point out that we in
the cosmic microwave background
community are also very interested in
the existence of magnetic fields and in
principle we could go far far back
because the cmb is produced at a time
when the universe was only .003 percent
of its current age or 380 000 years out
of 14 billion years roughly
so we can perhaps go back to the very
primordial essence of the universe using
the cosmic microwave background and this
has been a hope for both my friend and
colleague libon pagosian as well as my
friend and colleague hanmei vacaspati at
arizona state university
back in 1991 tanmay conjectured that
magnetic fields could have arisen during
what's known as the electro-weak phase
transition this is the time roughly less
than a millisecond or two after the big
bang when the electromagnetic force and
the weak nuclear force were unified into
one force or before that they were
unified and after that time period after
electroweak uh unification ended we then
manifest different phenomena as
electricity and magnetism whether or not
the earliest magnetic field energy could
produce a predictable pattern in the
primordial soup the primordial plasma
protons and electrons if they could
actually spin up the very first magnetic
fields this is another conjecture that
has gone on for a long time so we need
to push back even farther back in time
beyond the massive and tremendous
success of the lofar instrument that can
only probe you know out to red ships of
a few where these clusters of galaxies
exist we need to go back factors of a
thousand more in redshift and that is
potentially only observable using the
cosmic microwave background to detect
the existence of a primordial magnetic
field using the cosmic microwave
background radiation we would employ its
polarization and it's interesting all
the successes of the cmb to date have
all been measured without application or
appeal to using cmb's polarization but
now this could only be gotten out by
measuring what's called the faraday
effect which is allied with the
birefringence effect that i spoke about
in this video over here the amount of
faraday rotation of the plane of
electromagnetic polarization depends
very crucially on the amount of
electrons that are present in a plasma
but also the amount of magnetic field so
you can directly measure the strength of
magnetism by measuring how much
polarization rotation takes place but
looking for faraday rotation in the
cosmic microwave background radiation is
no easy feat it does require ultra
sensitive measurements of the cosmic
microwave backgrounds emote and b mode
polarization states as well as the
correlation between them and it is
somewhat degenerate with this type of
birefringent effect that we spoke about
in earlier videos and we'll continue to
speak about it nevertheless it is quite
interesting that we can look for the
signatures in many many different
wavelength regimes we can look at low
frequency radio emission we can look for
gamma ray emission or the lack of gamma
ray emissions surrounding these tev
blazars
and that measurement can also be
combined those measurements and low
frequency radio emission extremely high
gamma ray emission we can use that in
combination with millimeter wave
microwave measurements such as that as
going to be produced by the simon's
observatory can combine to give us a
narrower and narrower
parameter space over which cosmic
magnetism could arise
so this is quite fascinating whether or
not these magnetic fields which are
known to exist throughout the cosmos on
the smallest scales of you and me all
the way up to cosmic galaxy clusters and
perhaps even beyond that those
measurements
could lead to an understanding of what
happened at extremely early times as if
it weren't enough to go back billions of
years with galaxy clusters eight billion
years back to the cosmic microwave
background we could go back to perhaps
microseconds or maybe even billionths of
a second after the big bang if indeed
some phase transition
is responsible for the origin of matter
so
how does all of this relate to the
so-called hubble tension that exists
between cosmic microwave background
measurements of the universe's expansion
rate 380 000 years
after the big bang and the late time
relatively late time say billions of
years after the big bang
magnetic fields produce a very
particular type of energy it's called a
stress energy the type of stress energy
that's produced by an early magnetic
field can also contribute to the
friedman equations that we've talked
about in previous videos and that can
cause the universal expansion rate which
we call the hubble constant it can cause
that to vary over time and so you can
ask the hubble constant today and you
can compare it to what the hubble
constant would be evaluated when the cmb
was uh was produced 380 000 years after
the big bang and you compare those two
and they are discrepant how does this
come into play could be that there was
excess energy in the form of primordial
magnetic fields
that were again implanted by an as yet
unknown mechanism but these primordial
magnetic fields would cause the universe
to expand somewhat faster at early times
and so we could look and compare these
two these cosmic expansion rates and we
can ask the question as to whether or
not the discrepancy is caused not by
some exotic force or field quintessence
dark energy evolving but it could be a
very pros egg
solution one that involves you going no
farther than your kitchen refrigerator
to appreciate namely a primordial
cosmetic magnetic field